all the L
stormy I just watched the McDonald's
advert for nearly 2 minutes bro and this
is like one of the most Googled things
at the moment I heard Stony deleted a
free Palestine post and did a McDonald's
advert and and and honestly you gotten
the greatest in the
world so free Palestine fre Palestine
million I'm dead and I don't care who's
canceling
me just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you was
guys so I've got two videos for you guys
that we're going to react to storm Z and
chunks storm Z um was apparently Pro
Palestinian and he was shown Po and
whatever it is for that matter and for
some reason when the Price Is Right you
know when it's the price is too good you
know they made have an offer he couldn't
refuse you know it was not about you
know we would kill you stor if you do
not uh support McDonald's and take your
por off about Palestine no no it wasn't
life and death matter it was just about
the price being right they gave him a
good amount where this would make me
turn a blind eye to the oppression that
is going on that's why Allah tell us in
the Quran we have a principle that we
live by as Muslims is that speak the
truth even if it's against yourself or
your king it's not a price matter it's
not a valuable matter it's not a
material uh matter it's not about that
it's about principles it's about living
and doing things for the sake of Allah
meaning there is no other um ulterior
motives involved let's watch this ad and
let's see what is it that he had to sell
it out for let's see what he's promoting
let's see you know this disgusting food
mcdal if they paid me I eat McDonald's
yes this disgusted process food that
doesn't even Decay there's people have
posted after 10 15 years a burger still
you it's unbelievable and you want to
promote that disgusting rubbish food
anyways let's let's carry on but again
who cares do you really think somebody
who sells out the gazan and a
Palestinian do you think he cares about
the consumption of young kids who
obesity is on the rise and heart disease
and all this kind of stuff do you think
he cares about the the the people in UK
around the world he McDonald doesn't
care about what goes in their stomach
let alone the ones who have been blown
up in the pieces he's the video and
barbecue
sauce for us the barbecue sauce please
say that again why everyone got the same
voice here's your order thanks CU stor
me for Big Mike cheers C that's for me
order L
[Music]
stormy is that it this what everybody's
going on about this [__] advert as if
this is the best thing in the world bro
I just watched the McDonald's advert for
nearly 2 minutes bro and this is like
one of the most Googled things at the
moment I don't know what everyone's
raving about to be completely honest man
I I heard stormy deleted a free
Palestine post and didn't McDonald's
ever and this was it okay guys you saw
that for yourself Subhan Allah I mean um
when the guy reacted you know he was he
was saying why did they all sound the
same because they're all sellouts that's
why they all sound the same they that's
they all have the voice of Stormy
because they all sellouts like stormy
you know when you go to McDonald's and
buy McDonald's you are like stormy yeah
you you know there should be like a
disease where your voice starts sounding
like stormy yeah that's not a good thing
okay let me be honest with you that's
why they all sound the same why because
they all sell out that's for that matter
that's what it is so for me it's like
I'm unbelievable like this is this is
how what marketing is people go out
there and give the mouth most amazing
look you know it's all it's all the put
of Shan Shan beautifies we believe that
Satan beautifies things for us do you
get what I'm trying to say the reality
of it is not like that but it just
beautifies for us so watching this now
let's compare that to chunks yeah chunks
is in qar okay if I'm not mistaken and
by the way I'm in qar as well I've come
for a specific purpose and chunks if
you're here you it be lovely to see you
in sayam if not it's totally fine may
Allah bless and preserve you this is
chun's reaction and I just want you to
compare sellouts B and compare them to
people who actually stand by principles
who genuinely when they hate something
they hate it for the sake of Allah
nothing transactional here's what chunks
had to say a big slap in stormy's face
okay okay I'm telling you like let's
watch for for chunks is more stormy than
stormy himself more more like generally
so regardless of what happened today bro
you should be happy you should be over
the moon you should sleep with a smile
in your face head up highd and and
honestly you got on the greatest set in
the
world show show free Palestine free
Palestine million times dead and I don't
care who's canceling
me you smash we so proud of you okay
there you go guys Subhan Allah um y you
can see brothers and sisters sub Allah
he's proud he's wearing the flag he
could wear the flag and not speak about
it you know but he's doing the best of
his ability that's why the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him said if you
see evil try to stop with your hands
this can stopping two people fighting or
whatever it is and whatever it is for
that matter okay or a of a ruler you
have authority do something about it if
not speak out against it if not hate it
in your heart we know storms already
hates um I'm saying stormy please sorry
let me correct that chunks not stormy
chunks hates it in his heart but he also
speaks out against it and you can see
obviously I don't condem condone the
middle fingers that he done you know
maybe was a bit passionate the moment
and using F language but let's put that
to a side let's at the bigger picture um
as you can see he like I don't care who
cancels me yeah to me that speaks
volumes listen to me this a matter of
principle this a matter of enjoying good
and for and evil that's what Allah tells
us in the Quran let their rise amongst
you a group of people who would enjoying
good and forbid evil why because this is
what makes Islam and Muslims Muslims
because we enjoying evil if we let
everybody do the evil you are the silent
devil that's why we know in the Quran
when Allah told B is do not fish in the
Sabbath do not what did they do rather
they were trying to find loopholes and
trick Allah and they put the Nets a day
before and on the Sabbath of course
they're not fishing if you think about
technically they're not fishing but the
Nets catch the fishes so they're
thinking they're outsmarting God
Almighty okay and sadly that was what
bani Isel was known for yes not all of
them because Allah also tells us that
there were a group of them who abstained
from it who actually obeyed Allah
subhana tala but the ones who did not
Allah subhana destroy them what does the
scholar say the scholar say there was
three types number one the ones who
listen to the warning of Allah number
two there were those who were silent
what was happening they were not saying
nothing good or bad and then there were
those who participated in putting the
net Allah destroyed the ones who put the
Nets out and Allah also destroy the ones
who were quiet because they were the
silent Devils why because you can see
evil happening and you're not speaking
out against and saying don't do this do
not violate the laws of Allah okay
that's one thing number two Islam gives
great importance to the rights of
individuals so much so that there's free
condition of repentance when you sin
against God Almighty you stop the sin
you don't to repeat the sin and you try
not to go back to the sin however if you
have wronged somebody you have to ask
for their forgiveness if you owe them a
debt you have to pay it back if you have
backbitten them it is even advice that
you don't go and tell them by the way
you know was some friends that they and
I will speak of you no Islam says this
might cause tension between you two
because he might be like oh my gosh this
guy going speaks behind my back rather
not rather go speak good way SP of him
and give him charity and ask God
Almighty forgiveness there's great
emphasis on the wrong that's been done
on individuals and stormy shame on you
yes shame on you that once the specific
price was given to you that you go and
promote McDonald's these Zion supporting
dirt bags and not only that some
disgusting F I don't know how you
promote paid I'll beon if they paid me
10 million pound to promote McDonald I
tell them to hell why am I going to
promote something that harms children
that you know people eating these
disgusting processed food let alone a
company that support supports the
genocide that is happening so Subhan
Allah your priorities you don't even
care about the dead children let Al the
ones that are alive that are going to
die so to me the matter is clear guys
boycott this guy boy I mean I don't know
you shouldn't listen him regardless it's
Haram but anyways boyot him let him feel
it inshallah and do not U take from you
know enough to take from him but do not
see him as a friend he's not a friend
and let's do things for the sake of
Allah because in Islam doing things for
the sake of God Almighty means there is
no transaction involved that's all I'm
going to say brother and sisters may
Allah bless brother trun chunks
inshallah and preserve him and guide him
and guide myself and chunks may Allah
guide him to Islam to to understand that
not everything is money there's
something greater than that inshallah
and may Allah Elevate and and may Allah
open his heart to the spiritual realm of
Islam and the oness of God Almighty we
invite him to Islam inah it's never too
till next time